[Music]
how did you decide to become a hacker I
just spy on people and see what makes
them
click it takes research to figure out
the key players and learn all about them
their families their friends what they
care
about you have to understand the
company's organization I get a lot of my
information from the sales department
because they're always so quick and
eager people trust too easily they don't
look at the details I do it has to look
familiar this is where research is
important it's not some generic piece of
spam it's an email from their boss with
their company
signature it's written in the voice of
the boss it's what he would say if he
were writing this somebody else out
there already wrote all the code that
does the actual attack I'm just using it
in the
[Music]
attachment